exclusive audio from a key witness
before the January 6th committee it's
from the testimony of former National
Security adviser Michael Flynn and it
reveals the depth of the effort to
undermine American democracy back in
2020. Robert Costa has that part of the
story
tomorrow we the people are going to be
here and we want you to know that we
will not stand for a lie
ahead of the January 6 attack on the
capitol retired lieutenant general
Michael Flynn was a central figure in
the right-wing effort to block the
certification of the 2020 election but
when the house is January 6 committee
interviewed Flynn in March he repeatedly
invoked his Fifth Amendment right
against self-incrimination and said
little general Flynn do you believe in
the peaceful transition of power in the
United States of America
the fifth until now the committee has
only released Snippets of Flynn's
deposition but CBS News has obtained new
audio files that reveal more including
that he was questioned about whether he
pressure defense and intelligence
officials between November 3rd 2020 and
January 20th 2021 did you have any
conversations with any current or former
officials at the office of the Director
of National Intelligence regarding
election fraud or other irregularities
in the 2020 presidential elections
during the deposition Flynn was pressed
on whether he contacted a then top
intelligence official Ezra Cohen your
phone calls are calling did you tell him
the investigator kept pressing about a
second call to Cohen during the second
phone call with Mr Cohen did you tell
him that quote we need to have the
military take over the election and redo
the election unquote or something like
that
a person close to Cohen told CBS News
Flynn did call him twice alarming Cohen
who allegedly told Flynn he needed to
move on two people familiar with the
investigation say Cohen has spoken with
the January 6 committee at its request
Flynn's alleged contact with a top
Pentagon official came under the
spotlight too
around December 2020
if you contacted Mr Anthony
concept from the Department of Defense
regarding the 2020 election is that true
data in a statement to CBS news said in
part in December 2020 I never spoke with
Mike Flynn about anything but former
Federal prosecutor Scott Fredrickson
says the committee's line of questioning
tells us something about the potential
scope of the investigation this is not
the kind of stuff they just kind of pull
out of the hat
so one I think could reasonably assume
some other witness or Witnesses are
telling them that they had these kinds
of conversations that's quite a
revelation that's a stunning revelation
Flynn's attorney told CBS news that
Flynn availed himself of his
constitutional rights under the Fifth
Amendment upon the advice of counsel
that he chose not to dignify their
absurd questions was necessary to combat
yet another political Witch Hunt a
spokesman for the house select committee
declined to comment Gail
all right Bob we'll be watching we will
bring you full coverage of today's
January 6th house committee meeting in a
CBS News special report it starts at one
o'clock Eastern right here on CBS